- When you first learn
math, you see things like
two plus three
is equal to five,
or you might see six plus one
is equal to seven,
or you might see eight minus two
is equal to six.
And all of these, you might
think that the equal sign
just says, hey, give me the answer,
figure out what two plus three is.
Two plus three, well, the answer is five.
Six plus one, the answer is seven.
Eight minus two, the answer is six.
That's not quite right.
What the equal sign is saying is that
what's on the left side
is the same amount,
the same quantity, as what
is on the right-hand side.
It's saying that two plus three
is the same thing as five.
And you didn't have to write it this way.
You could have written,
you could have written five
is equal to two plus three.
You could write that three plus two
Notice, here, we're not
figuring out the answer,
we're just saying that
whatever three plus two is,
that's going to be the same thing
as whatever two plus three is.
We know that they both equal five.
You could even mix
addition and subtraction,
you could write, you could write that
six plus one is the same thing,
is equal to, eight minus one.
They are the same amount,
the same quantity.
What is six plus one, well, that's seven.
What's eight minus one,
well, that is seven.
So the equal sign does not mean
just give me the answer or just, you know,
add the numbers or subtract the numbers.
An equal sign is saying that
what's on the left-hand side
is the same amount as what's
on the right-hand side.
So with that in our brain,
let's write some statements
using equal signs, some
equations, you could even say,
using equal signs, and figure out
which of them are actually true.
So if I were to write down,
if I were to write down,
I won't even read it out,
'cause it might give it away.
If I were to write down
this, is this true?
Well, the number on the left here is 18,
the number on the left is
18, the number on the right
is a different number, it is 81, it is 81.
They swapped, or we swapped (chuckles),
the one and the eight,
they're in different places.
This is a different number, this is 81.
These are not equal.
These are not, not equal.
So this statement is not true.
And sometimes you might
even see someone do
something like this, that means not equal.
18 is not equal to 81.
Let's keep going.
What if I were to write,
what if I were to write nine minus three
plus two minus zero
is equal to, is equal to...
zero plus one minus one
plus eight, is this true?
Well, let's figure out
what the left-hand side is.
See, nine minus three is six,
plus two is eight, minus zero is eight.
So this, this, if I were to, if I were
to compute it, that's equal to eight.
And then on the right-hand
side I have zero plus one
minus one, well, one minus one is zero,
so this is all going to be eight.
So this is, this is
true, eight equals eight.
This is another way of writing eight,
nine minus three plus two
minus zero, this is eight.
And this is also eight, so once again
the equal sign is just saying that this,
what we have on the left, is the same
as what we have on the right.
Let's do another example.
Let's do another example,
let's do two more examples.
If I were to write this,
is this true?
Well, you might be tempted, hey, if I put
a one (chuckles) and a zero together,
it's gonna look like a 10,
but that's not, this is not
how we do mathematics, this
is not how we add things.
One plus zero is just one, so
this would be the same thing
as saying that 10 is equal
to one, which we know
is not true, so this is not
equal, this is not equal.
Let's do one more.
Let's say I had seven plus one
is equal to three plus four.
Is this equation true?
Well, what do we have on the left,
seven plus one is eight,
three plus four is seven.
These are not the same
quantity, they're not
the same amount, so these are not equal.
And we're done.